ever since the movie Toy Story came out
I as well as I'm assuming a lot of other
people really wanted a Buzz Lightyear
show everything he described about his
world just sounded so much fun flying
through space defeating the evil Emperor
Zurg fighting aliens blasting things
blowing him up it sounded like a show
that practically wrote itself
well Buzz Lightyear of Star Command was
the pilot film to get that show going
and as pilot films go it is pretty much
just an hour and a half long Saturday
morning cartoon but I mean that in all
the best ways it opens with the Toy
Story characters actually watching it on
the TV as if to already set up hey this
is meant to be like a Saturday morning
cartoon and that's exactly how it plays
out in the movie Buzz Lightyear played
again by Tim Allen is off again to fight
the evil Emperor Zurg
Zerg wants to get this technology known
as the Uni mind it's a device that the L
GM's you can guess what that stands for
use to communicate with one another to
become the most efficient race ever but
sir-- captures the device and plans to
use it for evil turning everybody's
minds as diabolical as his so it's up to
buzz of course to go in and stop him but
the one downside is they wanted to have
a partner but of course he doesn't want
a partner why because he lost his last
partner warp and the pain was just too
near and so of course he turns away the
others that try to come to his side a
ranger named Nova who's also a princess
but doesn't like being a princess a
bumbling janitor who has dreams of
adventure and a nerdy robot who always
has those clever one-liners this setup
is of course about as stock as you can
get but the thing is with the way it's
written it's aware that it's doc and it
has fun with it there's a lot of great
comedic talent behind these characters
including Nicole Sullivan Larry Miller
and Wayne Knight who's practically
unrecognizable azarkh I think they're
distorting his voice a little bit but
whatever they're doing they make it
sound great it's both kind of menacing
but super hilarious at the same time
you're telling me my
I already know my plan the atmosphere
gives you what you're looking for with
space men and women traveling through
space and shooting up aliens but it also
has this clever side to it
Rangers condition status excellent let's
roll the comedy is both mocking but kind
of paying homage to these sort of 80
Saturday morning tropes like the climax
is stopping xored from pointing his
death ray to the planet of orphans and
widows there's like a five-minute
conversation decade to getting nose rigs
why can't we have nose rings
because nose rings of our punks little
mister well if you can take on Zerg
alone I don't see why XR can't get a
nose ring I was just asking the question
I'm not the one getting a nose ring and
all these characters egos do great at
working off of each other trying to show
off trying to be funny and ultimately
succeeding at the end but just barely
it doesn't really have any twists or
surprises or at least none that you
can't see coming a mile away but again
it feels like that's the intention
it's trying to give us that silly
version of transformers or Thundercats
or Silverhawks except there's a
self-awareness that makes for a lot of
funny comedy I'd say the one nitpick I
have in the entire thing is that booster
the big janitor guy doesn't really seem
to have a point the other cadets
definitely proved their worth but this
guy just sort of acts afraid and screams
and I don't know I get why he was there
as the scaredy-cat character but I
didn't really get why he was there in
terms of the story but again story is
not a big thing here what is big is the
adventure the comedy the characters and
they all do great
they'll again in that cheesy Saturday
morning way that they're obviously going
for if I was a little kid I would love
this this is the exact show I would want
to see looking at Buzz Lightyear in Toy
Story it feels like this is the show the
toy was based on these were the
adventures that they made him out of
it's a few had even the tiniest interest
in seeing this at all okay like I said
obviously for kids but it has just the
right amount of comedy action and charm
give it a watch and have fun going to
infinity
and beyond
you